good morning Hank it's Tuesday this is
the story of three mornings first my
morning wake up drag myself out of bed
make it to the kitchen and then with
Sarah's help make the coffee I used to
treat coffee as merely a kind of
medicine the OCD meds I take make me
drowsy in the morning and coffee helps
that but now I luxuriate in drinking my
delicious ridiculously fresh coffee each
morning because I know a little
something about how much care and
expertise goes into exceptional coffee
what about a morning somewhere else so
this is Marta every day she wakes up in
Colombia on a small farm she owns and
operates herself she also enjoys a
morning coffee before heading out to
inspect her trees on the rugged Hillside
I don't know if I've ever mentioned it
before but our company dftba runs the
awesome coffee club and Marta is one of
the farmers who has produced the beans
that I drink every day recently a couple
people from dftba headed down to
Colombia to learn from Marta and other
Farmers we work with because Marta is an
expert on every aspect of the coffee
process that touches her farm from
planting the trees to harvesting the
beans to wet Milling the beans into
parchment and her passion shows in the
taste of the coffee so most Colombian
coffee is not produced on huge farms run
by big companies in fact 98 of coffee
from the country is produced by small
family-owned Farms like martas with
large suppliers than buying their beans
in the past this structure led to those
large buyers short-changing farmers and
playing them off each other for the
lowest price possible but with help from
sustainable coffee suppliers like such a
Fina Farmers like Marta are now changing
that relationship so that they know the
prevailing prices and can negotiate much
more effectively now Marta and her
fellow farmers can share transparently
what they're being paid which has raised
prices especially for the best beans and
that's good news for Marta it's also
good news for us her being paid fairly
is part of why awesome coffee is you
know awesome but because we've become
quite a big coffee company quite quickly
we also work with larger producers
provided they're working toward a better
shared future and that brings us to our
third morning Dolores wakes up early in
salgar Colombia she works in HR and her
breakfast is hurried as she gets her
family and herself ready something most
of us can relate to but at least when
she gets to work there will be coffee
indeed there's never not coffee at the
green coffee company one of the larger
producers in Colombia focused on the
well-being of their farmers and
Community the green coffee company runs
36 coffee farms in salgar employing
hundreds of people who tend to the
plants pick the beans and process them
so that they're ready for roasting each
of these positions is highly skilled
taking time and training but it is too
often poorly paid work with limited
benefits and that's why Dolores is
focused on addressing those with the
help of the green coffee company Dolores
help start a pilot program for the GCC
that sought to provide far more
comprehensive support than just pay for
workers and as a result retention has
improved dramatically as has the quality
of farmers lives
[Music]
when Folks at dftba talked with divorce
she was unshakable in her belief that
all workers including agricultural
workers should be able to share the same
benefits paid time off sick leave
pensions and steady pay so the call for
change is coming from inside the house
and as a result the green coffee company
has become the kind of place we want to
do business with and now our beans come
from there too and what really strikes
me when I drink this coffee is that it
it tastes good like really really good
and that's the result of a huge
sprawling collaboration involving so
many people every cup of awesome coffee
would be impossible without Farmers like
Marta and labor activists like Dolores
and hundreds of other people from
Colombia to Missouri where our coffee is
roasted by first crack to Missoula
Montana where it is packed and shipped
to your home too often corporations mask
or minimalize or even invisibilize that
work because they don't want you to
think about it while you're consuming
their products but at the awesome coffee
club we do want you to think about it we
want you to know that the people who
made your coffee are talented and
passionate Marta is out in her Farm
every day working with her plants and
planning how to make her Farm even
better the next year Dolores goes into
work every day and makes sure that all
the hands that touch these beans are
given the conditions to be passionate
about coffee making and the fact that we
can work with these suppliers who make
sure that our coffee is truly awesome is
such a gift to us and to every one of
the over ten thousand subscribers to the
awesome coffee club and lastly there's
the little fact that we donate 100 of
our profit to charity between awesome
coffee awesome socks and Sun Basin soap
over the last three years we've been
able to donate over five million dollars
to fight maternal and infant mortality
in Sierra Leone nobody's paying me to
say this Hank because I'm an unpaid
intern for the awesome coffee Club but
it really is the best coffee in the
world and you can feel good about
drinking it thanks to the hard work of
Marta Dolores and so many others
awesomecoffeeclub.com Hank I'll see you
on Friday